I knew it was going to be hostile
because we are in a bizarre episode of
human history in which normal people
that understand the truth are fighting
against sort of a quasi-religious
authoritarian cult so I knew that it was
going to be difficult and
but what normally happens in these
situations is you get the the people
that that are part of the cult that will
be very very angry with you and uh shape
dogmatic mantras at you and that's
that's understandable and that's I I
accept that and they are almost invited
because they they prove my point really
as to why I don't want them in
women-only spaces but once we'd stepped
into calling me a white nationalist
um and a Nazi which was done by people
in Authority then I'm fair game just to
be killed in the street so it it just
took on a a totally different uh feel